انا شفتك فين قبل كده
جمال جمال الصواف
وما اظنش ان احنا تقابلنا قبل كده على فين
يا باشا ان شاء الله
الامن الوطني الفنان محمد فراج اهلا بيك
وكل سنه وانت طيب
مسلسل حرب يمكن جف اخر 10 ايام في رمضان
ناس ما كانتش متوقعاه كلمني كده عن ايه
اللي حمسك لهذا المسلسل والفرق معك ان هو
جاي في النص التاني من رمضان اللي حمسني
للتجربه ديت وجود الاستاذ احمد نادر كذلك
كمخرج للعمل
دي اول حاجه طبعا في في عوامل كتير زي
شركه الانتاج زي الدور
طبعا هو الدور عموما بالنسبه لي هو اللي
بيشدني اول حاجه بتشدني ببص لها ولكن
الظروف السنه دي كانت مختلفه شويه لانه
الوقت كان قليل قوي قوي قوي ومن ساعه لما
جالي
فكره المسلسل ديه بتدور لحد ما صورت كانوا
تقريبا اربع خمس ايام فما كانش بالنسبه لي
عندي فتره تحضير كافيه وبالتالي كان
اختبار صعب جدا بالنسبه لي وتحدي جديد لقد
اخترتموني ولا يقتموني ولا لست بافضلك
يعني ما بقاش ورايا غيركم الكميه دي
والعدد ده بتاع جيش ما هو عشان يبقى جيش
قصاد جيش عملت كذا
عمل صينيه
فيلم الممر
ودلوقتي حرب ومسلسل الاختيار شاركت برضه
فيه
بتشوف ايه اهميه هذه الاعمال الاعمال اللي
بتبقى من دي يعني
هي اللي بتعرف الاجيال اللي ما عاشتش
الفتره دي
ايه التاريخ وايه الحقائق وايه الاكاذيب
ومين صح ومين غلط
ومين فرط مين ومين ضحك مين ومين خان ومن
فاهم قصدك فبتبقى في اسئله اجوبتها مهمه
تبقى في اسئله مهمه جدا جدا اجوبتها
بت بتورخ وبتبان في الاعمال
مش قادر ابص في عينه وانا مهزوم مكسور
والشهد هندفنهم هنا دي ارضنا برده حرب من
غير نهايه يا احنا
الغرفه 207 شد الناس جدا وكله منتظر الجزء
التاني عشان حتى يفهم حاجات من النهايه
بتاعه الجزء الاولاني ده اخباره ايه
هتخلصوه قريب ده واحنا اصلا كمان اعلنا
عنه يعني بشكل رسمي انه في جزء ثاني من
الغرفه 207
المفروض انه دلوقتي بيتم الانتهاء من
المراحل الاولى من كتابه الجزء التاني
والفلتره بقى هتحصل مع الوقت لحد ما نبتدي
تصوير ان شاء الله على في الربع الاخراني
من السنه يعني شهر سبعه شهر ثمانيه كده
يعني
صباح الخير صباح النور يا دكتوره
امال حضرتك خرجت امتى من شويه كده
اصل انا متعوده بصحى بدري كل يوم
هشوفك النهارده
انا هنا طول اليوم
لو حضرتك احتاجتي اي حاجه انا تحت
امرك ردود افعال عليك كثير يا خبر ابيض ده
كلام كبير قوي من عند ربنا لا لا الحمد
لله رب العالمين اه طبعا طبعا طبعا الحمد
لله رب العالمين كرم كرم كبير من عند ربنا
اللي حصل لي في الغرفه يعني الحمد لله رب
العالمين شكرا يا فراج وكل سنه وانت طيب
وانت بصحه وسلامه عيد سعيد عليكم كلكم
[موسيقى]